- Nope, not on camera.
I wanna give you a piece of advice.
Stuff gets on the internet
and it doesn't go away.
You hear me?
This is actually very salient advice.
Hi, my name is Kate McKinnon,
I'm here with BuzzFeed.
I'm going to answer some fan questions
about the upcoming animated film Leap
and some other stuff
and I'm gonna play with
puppies while I do it.
Hello little one.
Yes, hello, hi.
Hi little ones, hello.
(squeaky dog toy)
You over here.
I'm gonna call you Paul.
And your name will be Grizzabelle.
You know, tough to answer questions while
there is such sweetness
and love abounding.
I have had only positive interactions
in relation to my impressions of people,
which makes me happy
because I do them with love
and I hope that the
people who I do them of
really like them, isn't that right Angela?
You know its really fun just
running around backstage
when everyone's getting changed
and it feels like a middle
school play all over again.
Sometimes you see someone naked.
The trick is, I guess, fear.
You don't wanna ruin it by laughing.
But I often do.
We haven't spoken much.
John, what is it like being so cute
that you should be eaten?
Is it hard knowing that
you should be eaten
because you're so cute?
I think my Emmy award has
run away to another continent
because I have not heard
from him or her in months.
Oh you don't like that jacket?
You think that's a bad fashion choice?
Let's see what we can do with this jacket.
I am a cool dude, my name is Rachel.
Look at what a cool dude I am.
You gotta believe in yourself
and you just have to work
harder at it than you've ever
worked at anything before
in your life.
And if you keep doing that
and keep believing in yourself
great things do happen.
You just have to work super
hard and if you have a passion,
that's the most beautiful thing in life
and you just have to
bust out and do it baby.
My passion used to be comedy but now
it is these four puppies, exclusively.
AHHH!
Can we have lunch please?
Can we stop and eat?
We never eat, have you noticed that?
We're working our way through.
Do their mouths smell like garbage?
Yeah.
Do I want them to kiss me on the mouth?
That's an interesting question.
There is no backstory,
I just like to salute.
And I guess it became a thing.
Hey, hey, hey.
My son Nino who I hope
is not watching this
because he would not like to see me
fawning over some dogs.
He's doing very well even though
it is very hot in the summer
and he doesn't love that.
Before 10 minutes ago it might
have been something different
but now it is, Swimming in Fur.
Do you wanna read the question, Rachel?
Read that, read that question.
Can you read English?
No, you can only read Russian.
He's cute but he doesn't have a future
as a professional interviewer.
I think sometimes you don't get to-
hello.
You don't get to- hello.
Oh you wanna play fetch?
You're not in the room
with the people that you're
acting against and sometimes you've done
your parts on different days.
Do you wanna ... Grizzabelle ...
You're Rufus.
So sometimes you don't get to
see who you're acting against.
Oh my goodness.
Maddie Ziegler is the most
amazing dancer I've ever seen.
And I'm so obsessed with her.
I was obsessed with her even before
she did her first Sia video.
What are you eating?
And so- Ow.
You're a stinker, Rachel.
I was so excited that she was doing this
because I'm so obsessed
with her as an artist
and she's so young and
it's crazy that she's so,
such an amazing innovator.
Will you do me a favor, Rachel and just
go into my pocket and stay there?
I'm gonna walk out of here
and just don't leave okay?
You can come to my house
and live in my house.
How does that sound?
He said yes.
He?
Yep.
Just in conclusion, all of these
fabulous little puppies are adoptable
at North Shore Animal League America,
which happens to be where
I got my son Nino from.
And all of my childhood cats as well.
It's an incredible facility.
Thank you so much for
lending me these friends.
And would someone please
take them into their homes
because Nino would get too jealous.
All of the puppies have left me.
What does that say about me?